the United States has agreed that the
Allies can send F-16 fighter jets to
Ukraine what is the F-16 fighter jet and
will that provide a game-changing
capability for Ukraine
the F-16 Fighting Falcon is a very
capable modern fighter aircraft that's
capable of multi-role missions in other
words offering air-to-air shooting down
other aircraft but also to delivering
bombs in an air-to-ground mode it's been
around since 1979 but it's been
continuously upgraded ever since and
it's one of the most modern most capable
military platforms around it's a 1500
mile an hour Mark II capable aircraft
carries a 20 millimeter cannon and can
deliver a range of air-to-air and
air-to-ground weapons as a result it's
one of the most widely exported military
aircraft around with over 5 000
available in service with countries all
around the world
the announcement by President Biden at
the G7 conference that America would
endorse the gifting of f-16s is really
important but there are no Nations yet
stepping forward to actually offer F-16
platforms one of the challenges is that
each of these f-16s is a different block
standard is a different software
standard different radar different
electronic warfare and one of the things
that Ukraine will probably need is
between 20 and 30 aircraft but of a
common software standard and that will
be quite difficult for the International
Community to provide one of the ways
that they may be able to do that is that
some of the operators of F-16 aircraft
like Denmark and Holland are looking to
retire their fleets of f-16s and replace
them with F-35 aircraft and that
therefore might leave a small Fleet of
f-16s which would be able to be donated
to Ukraine of a single common standard
president zielinski would want the
fighter jets to be available as soon as
possible the harsh reality though is
it's going to take some time for a
couple of reasons one of which is pilot
training at the moment the US have taken
two experienced Ukrainian fighter pilots
across the US to see how long the
training would take and they believe
that within intense period of grand
school extensive use of simulators and
flying training that they might be able
to get that train done in four months
and another 10 Ukrainian Pilots are on
their way over but almost certainly that
will not be complete by this year's end
the second issue is how many aircraft
can be provided and when they're
available but the main point for all of
that is that it's unlikely we're going
to see f-16s over the battlefield for
this spring summer offensive
the announcement is significant for two
main reasons one of which is president
zielinski has been beating a drum for
the last year about having fighter
aircraft to be able to protect Ukraine's
skies and what has been interesting is
the International Community over the
past year has gradually opened up its
War chests as confidence in Ukraine's
capability has increased starting with
anti-tac weapons then short-range
artillery then longer range artillery
and then tanks and president zielinski
almost certainly has been telling
Western leaders if we have been quicker
providing this military capability would
we be in a different position on the
battlefield today as a result he doesn't
want to learn those same lessons again
and it's imploring the International
Community to open the floodgates to
allow him to have Western Jets therefore
this announcement President Biden is
incredibly important the second reason
it's important is because President
Putin almost certainly thinks he has
time on his side that the West's
appetite for this war will wane as we
get into next winter and the reality is
now that with this commitment of
military jets the f-16s this is a
multi-year 5 or 10-year Arrangement that
will make a huge difference to Ukraine's
military capability for the long term
that will be very concerning for
President Putin
foreign
ly this decision does raise the question
that given there's a U.S presidential
election next year could the outcome of
that election affect this decision
um who knows what the future may hold
but this is not a decision for the U.S
to export F-16 aircraft from its own
inventory this is giving the Allies
permission to do that and re and if that
decision was to be reversed that would
have huge political implications not
only for the us but the West therefore
as we stand at the moment we don't know
what the U.S will do but it's very
unlikely to be renege on this deal